good morning believe nation today's
message is don't just plan do over to
you Markus notch Larson awake school TV
go I think that the best advice I could
give everyone is don't listen to advice
but if you are going to listen to advise
them making sure you actually do
something is a good advice if you just
sit around planning something end up
doing it you're not actually going to
get to know it I find that there are two
kinds of entrepreneurs there's a kind
who just run headfirst into every
opportunity and have no planning and
usually these are the really extroverted
super extroverted type-a personalities
they don't like the plan to just like to
do do do do do but they're often not
going in the right direction because
they have no plan then we've got the
over planners these are the people who
plan plan plan plan want to make the
perfect plan it has to be amazing one
hundred percent accurate before they
launch and they they plan themselves a
destined and never actually do anything
and these people I find are the ones who
are usually a lot more introverted and
thinking and like to have all the
details lined up remember the answer is
you have to be able to do both right you
have to be able to plain and you have to
be able to do if you just do your
running aimlessly around if you just
plan you're not getting anything done so
you have to be able to encompass both
strategies to help you create something
that will be spectacular as you grow and
if you don't have those skill sets both
of them yourself you might want to
partner up with somebody who can
compensate for your weaknesses so my
question the day today is do you like to
apply in too much do you like to do too
much and not playing or you a good
mixture of both I'm really curious to
find out leave it in the comments below
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day UT to believe and i'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events presso away
expreso keep me going